99% of people are self sabotaging their
YouTube videos and they don't even know
it the ultimate formula for business is
no like and trust and this is true for
YouTube as well so the question is how
do you build trust in your content what
are the mistakes you could be making
that's actually hurting trust and what
is the Ultimate key to not just getting
a viewer or a subscriber but to
connecting with someone and creating a
raving fan in this episode of the think
media podcast we're going to be
discovering the five elements of trust
from Dr Henry Cloud's book and we're
going to see how those apply to writing
YouTube scripts building our businesses
our marketing messaging overall and this
is a super practical episode that you'll
be able to apply immediately so let's
dive in today's episode of the think
media podcast is brought to you by VP
podcast.com once a year we do a special
sale on our signature program called
video ranking Academy and that's at VR
podcast.com but I'll tell you a little
bit more about that later all right now
let's dive into the five elements of
trust and talk about how these are
directly relevant to every YouTube video
we make and really every action we take
in our businesses the elements are
number one understanding number two
motive number three ability number four
character and number five track record
now we're going to go through each one
practically but let me ask you a
question have you ever turned on a video
and watched watched somebody
communicating saw a certain video maybe
a public speaker maybe somebody
communicating any kind of message and
there was some reason you didn't quite
trust them maybe they were saying the
right things but you felt a distance you
had your radar up something seemed off
well why is that and how do we fix that
have you ever turned on a video and
maybe you didn't know why but you found
wow I'm really connecting with this
Creator I'm starting to really trust
them and I don't know what it is about
what they're doing well there's actually
a science to trust and if we're
intentional to include these elements in
our videos our videos will not just
perform better but the bigger vision of
what you're trying to build with YouTube
the bigger online business that you're
trying to build will do better because
people do business with people they know
like and Trust they first got to know
you and that's why you should subscribe
to the podcast to get discovered get
your video clicked on keep people
watching grow your channel they got to
just discover you that you need the
actual impression do they even know you
exist then they got to decide if they
like you some First Impressions add some
value you're you're making a little bit
of connection at the like stage but if
someone's ever going to trust you trust
you maybe the affiliate program you're
talking about the affiliate product your
own product doing business with you
hiring you for a Service hiring you as a
freelancer if they're going to go all
the way there well what can we do to
accelerate and help people arrive at
that destination what can we do to
communicate better and make that
connection of trust and what could be
hurting us well let's start with number
one understanding so here's what
understanding means you can trust
someone when you feel your needs are
understood felt and cared about they get
you and they understand what makes you
feel good they have taken the time to
listen this is the law of empathy the
foundational aspect of trust is
understanding the needs feeling ings and
desires of the other person highlighting
The Importance of Being mirrored so you
might be wondering well how could I
possibly listen to the audience when I'm
making a one-way YouTube video and I
would challenge you this foundational
principle is what separates mediocre and
great content creators because we've
said it this way the Creator who
understands the viewer best wins so let
me ask you do the people watching your
content feel under understood well Sean
how would I know that they do well one
of the ways would be the language you
use the empathy you
express if someone's watching your video
and you are able to communicate I can
relate to what you've gone through
because I've been where you are the word
choice you use and even the topics you
talk about could
express you being able to understand
your audience in fact people who build
huge audiences and have huge followings
the people who really follow them at a
raving fan level often times feel UND
this person gets me they understand me
well that's not by accident that
individual because of their past
experiences and the way they're
communicating so what are some ways that
you could actually include this in a
video script one of my favorite ways is
using the word
frustrating you would say do you want to
accomplish this desire are you
interested in reaching this goal you
know it's frustrating when you're not
reaching it and when you have this set
back and that setback and if you tap
into maybe where you are a few years ago
in your journey what were those
frustrating points by
articulating the pain points and the
problems and the frustrations of the
viewer you are creating a connection
where they're like oh man this person
understands where I am and this is
foundational so before you display your
expertise and before you share your
amazing answers and before you do all
these other things the foundational
element of trust is understanding
another language you could include in
your script is do you want to reach this
goal do you want to achieve this
ambition do you want to solve this
problem you know it feels overwhelming
trying to raise a child for the first
time I've been there I can relate so you
can intentionally include the
understanding element in your video
script it's scary when you can't get
business
funding when you need to make payroll
maybe you have a loan product so you're
including you're using language
that is relating to what the audience
could feel you can trust someone when
you that you feel that your needs are
understood felt and cared about so what
is your target audience's needs what is
your ideal audience that the content
you're creating for
what where do they feel misunderstood
don't we like the political candidates
and the people running for office that
we feel like can understand us the best
a lot of people are frustrated and have
tension in light CU they feel like
nobody understands me I'm misunderstood
I'll apply each of these elements to my
uh personal Niche which is helping you
with YouTube and so I try to communicate
elements of understanding being like
listen I understand I have a team today
but I've been where you are I've had to
shoot the video and edit the video and
do all the steps all by myself it's felt
lonely it's felt
discouraging and sometimes I wanted to
quit but I was reminded that YouTube is
worth it and on the other side of
ranking videos and building your channel
is passive income and freedom so don't
quit maybe you've experienced some of
these things at think media I'm doing my
best to include understanding and this
challenges us to continue to read the
comments to if possible talk to your
target audience meaning like literally
call them or try to get them on the
phone or get them on a zoom call because
the Creator who understands the viewer
best wins it's going to inform your
topics it's going to inform your titles
when you're using language that they
understand and when you continue to
listen and you can listen on the
internet you can listen to Big Data big
groups of people surveys on your YouTube
Community tab you can talk to
individuals and when you come
from this place of empathy and have an
detailed understanding of the needs and
the feelings and the
desires of the person that you're going
to want to help you've just laid the
strongest Foundation possible for
building trust the last part and we
already touched it is that if you can
relate to your audience so I want to
encourage you the person you're most
powerfully positioned to help is the
person you were yesterday or last
year and so one of the things you can
tap into is trying to go back and
remember how did it feel for you when
you were in debt and overwhelmed or
discouraged or overweight or whatever it
is you're YouTube channel helps people
with by taking time to just weave in an
element of I can relate and sometimes
saying I can relate can feel
condescending so there's kind of an art
form to it you're not like you know it's
not like the person born with a silver
spoon being like I can relate to the
struggle if there's dissonance and
there's not truth there and authenticity
there doesn't work but what hopefully
you're building your YouTube channel
around a problem you've solved around a
result you've achieved around something
your passionate about you you put the
time in so you can relate to having
equal fandom for that particular game or
that particular subculture Niche all of
those things number one understanding
nobody even talks about this but if you
can help the audience feel understood
and seen and cared about in your videos
then you're going to have an unfair
Advantage which brings us to number two
which is motive their motive is for you
not just themselves the person
communicating this is what the viewer
wants they want the motive to be for you
and not just for themselves that means
that they have your back they will do
nothing to harm you they want the best
for you and even at times they are
willing to experience their own lost or
cost and having a genuine care for
others well-being think about that how
that applies to the internet how many
people on the Internet or on YouTube do
you think that their motive is for you
not just themselves that they truly have
your back that you will do nothing to
harm them now mind you we have to build
all five of these to have trust you're
probably already seeing how powerful
this is you're being like this is why I
don't trust my partner this I don't
trust my boyfriend or girl like this is
why I don't trust like I don't even
think they have my best interest in mind
but you can see keeping it in that
YouTube vertical okay so how can you
communicate your motive in video there's
something powerful
about of course we want to trust
somebody where we all know I think that
someone creating content a business
owner of course part of their motive is
to make money is to sell a product is to
get you to click on a link is to so like
motive is not just altruistic like it's
just pure like there's a business aspect
to creating content or anything but the
key here is their motive is for you not
just themselves so per my personal
example for this is oftentimes when
we're talking about maybe products we
have for sale at think media I'll say
and listen like I like to be really
transparent it's like and listen we are
a business and we do make money selling
books or selling online courses but I
want you to understand our mission here
is to help you win on YouTube and we are
committed to that process here's some of
the ways we back it up the amount of
staff we hire and faculty we hire that
supports you in private groups like we
will not do anything to harm you as far
as it depends on us and we want what's
best for you and we have your back and
we understand that premium
online courses or high quality books
that took years to write and decades to
learn that it's a value exchange so if
money is being
exchanged we just want you to get more
value than you paid for that if you pay
$10 for a book you're getting thousands
or hundreds of dollars of value in
exchange and so what's the motive and
people can sense your motive in how
you're communicating but also if you can
help people understand what your motive
is by weaving that into your script in
some cases maybe you aren't selling
anything but if somebody can truly feel
through your content that your YouTube
channel is about helping them get a
result helping people serving people if
that's the priority and so how can you
in your next video communicate your
motive because if viewers don't trust
your motive they're not going to trust
you at all and I think there's some
inner work to be done you might be
challenged by this question and say
actually when I think about my motive
it's actually kind of selfish like I I
don't even care about the viewer I just
care about money like I like so then you
have the opportunity to change your
motive um I know that for me this is a
continual work I I think okay is my
calendar and my priorities and the way
we're Staffing and the way that we're
investing money and the way we're
creating content and the actions that
we're doing we are for sure optimizing
to make profit in the business so this
is why we wrote down core values like
you know Purpose Driven like the Bible
is our blueprint like love above all
because it then reminds me like let's
keep our motive on track of course we've
got practical business results but let's
make sure not just me now but our entire
team is thinking about this like this is
not just about us this is about helping
you win and one of the ways you could
say this is and here's my goal and you
know the goal of this channel the goal
of this business and here's here's the
goal we've created an incredible product
that solves this problem and my goal is
that you would love it so much you would
subscribe you would enter your credit
card information you would like because
it and it would be a win-win that's the
goal and that's going to be the ultimate
sales um message right if you can create
a win-win win win win people love the
product you get money you can support
your business yourself your team and
they love it and everybody wins and so
it's knowing what is in it for you and
what is in it for me and my belief is
that your income is directly correlated
to the amount of value that you give to
the
marketplace and so that as business
owners as creators in the Creator
economy building online businesses this
is an important mindset and belief to
have because you're GNA make enough
money if you deliver enough value I
actually believe it's kind of a law of
the universe that if you deliver enough
value in a video and the video is
wellmade and well positioned it will get
lots of views and then YouTube will pay
you and if you deliver a lot of video
value in your free content then people
will be like wow this person is legit I
can see that they can get me actual
results I'm sure their paid content is
pretty good and even if their paid
content is backed by like a crazy
satisfaction guarantee I see that
they've removed all risk I really could
see that they're doing their best to
like put me as the priority they're here
to help me win number two is motive so
if you want to build trust Brick by
Brick number one how can you articulate
and weave into your content that you
understand the feelings and the needs
and the desires of the other person how
can you communicate your motive and
that's a question I think just being
aware of what's going through VI viewers
Minds whether consciously or
unconsciously the skepticism of today's
viewer is saying has this person even
taken the time to understand me what is
this person motive are they is are they
purely for themselves or or what's in it
for me what's in it for them which
brings us to number three and that's
ability what does this mean ability or
capacity to guard Andor deliver what you
trust with them you know a spouse would
say does this person have the
ability to guard my
secrets you know somebody who has known
you shared something private with them
and then they told everybody you you're
like they don't have the ability to
guard this information the opposite is
also deliver on what you trust with them
this would include skills so are they
able to actually pull it off like for
example what we learn is that trust can
exist in some areas and not in other
areas and that's not necessarily A Bad
Thing meaning I trust a gardener to do
well with my garden but I don't
necessarily trust that person to fix my
car and that's not a bad thing I know
based on the Legacy and the testimonials
and the history that and the way the
gardener is positioned that that's their
ex area of expertise so if I understand
that this Gardener understands my pain
points and what I want my yard and my
garden to look like and then I
understand that their motive is yes they
need to get paid they're in business but
they like really want to help me win and
they have my back and they they're so
obsessed with making my garden or my
yard awesome and then they have the
ability to fulfill on it then these are
building blocks of trust the opposite
side right would be you might have
massive credibility in one area and you
have people who trust you and have a
reason to put their trust in you in one
area and not in another and that's not
even an ethical thing it's a skill set
thing so that's what ability
means so how do we weave this into our
scripts and our
videos do you have any artifacts that
demonstrate your
ability I mean and a YouTube We I teach
YouTube right think media teaches
YouTube I think now we have three silver
play buttons think media podcast video
influencers Sean canel silver play
buttons and then a gold play button for
think media that's four personal
channels we've got a monday.com board
and all kinds of pictures on our success
wall of students that have gotten those
same results which those two those would
be artifacts in both cases they' be
artifacts that I've personally been able
to get some results on YouTube and that
I'm able to help other people get
results on YouTube and those are a
visual element so one of the things you
could include in videos is do you have
an award or do you have Decor or do you
have artifacts like physical objects
that demonstrate your ability if you
don't that's fine how is there other
ways you could show your
results so to accelerate trust as a
business owner as a content creator as
somebody who's creating maybe free
content that you hope leads to your
products Services your
agency you need to demonstrate your
ability and you can accelerate trust by
the way when you apply all five of these
tips what maybe used to
take weeks or months for someone to
build trust can now be happening on the
internet on autopilot if you're making
the right videos and including the right
Elements by the way if you do the
opposite of these things you could be
hurting trust or just missing elements
of your video that are so important so
again make sure to listen until the end
of this episode because we still have so
much more to cover and each of these
Builds on one another so if you weave
into your content even as you
storytelling a point can you share an
example of somebody else you've helped
achieve a
result also creating interest for the
viewer you know it kind of reminds me so
I'll I'll I talk about Mary a lot you
know I go this reminds me of Mary from
Mar's Nest she joined our program video
ranking Academy when she was 60 she was
afraid to get on camera didn't know how
to make videos didn't know how to turn
the camera on was super nervous and
didn't know where to start but as she
followed our 7R
system she began to
implement those tips and today she's
about to hit a million subscribers she
has a book deal from random house she's
ranked videos she's created passive
income and when I tell the story too uh
I'll talk there's all kinds of powerful
aspects of it it could be she lives in
different regions she's a cooking
channel so certain case studies build
trust in certain areas because you might
go okay you can help a cooking channel
you could help someone like Mary but can
you help a real estate agent so
depending on the environment that you're
communicating and who you're
communicating to the case studies you
share the examples you share should
reinforce the trust you're trying to
build with a particular type of person
and of course you have to use all of
these you don't have to but our
recommendation is that you use them with
honesty transparency and ethically
meaning like if I had never actually
helped someone in real estate it would
be an overreach if I said I can help you
with YouTube in real estate but I have
in that particular case so I probably
wouldn't tell them Mary's Nest story on
a video with real estate TS I wouldn't I
would talk about uh Levi lassic read
YouTube secrets and and in 18 months did
90 million Topline Revenue with 3
million real estate commissions from
implementing those tips so that would
demonstrate
ability and one of the other ways to
demonstrate ability is demonstrate that
you can help
people by actually helping people wow
it's pretty profound but no I'm serious
like one of the cool things about free
YouTube videos especially if eventually
you want someone to do something else
with you is that
whether you have case studies or silver
play buttons or gold play buttons or not
if by following what you teach share and
educate in your YouTube video people
apply it and they go oh my gosh it works
you know how much trust was built right
there how much acceleration of trust
they go okay they go one this person
understood my paino because they just
solved it two their motive is clearly to
help me because they just helped me and
then three they have the ability to help
me cuz they just helped me so sometimes
what could be broken in your business is
the fact that your content or your free
content or that your Solutions are
inferior at this point and maybe that's
a hard pill to swallow but just
meaning if you want people to trust that
you have the ability to help them then
actually help them and in the creater
economy you do this at the beginning for
free which is also really wild that's
kind of a New Concept some people may be
even more modernly the pendulum is swung
and there's like entitlement cuz like
everything is free on YouTube but like
it you think about it like literally
think about what's free on YouTube and
when people start to see man you can
actually help me man trust is built um
and so that is ability let's go to
number four and if you're watching on
the YouTube version please smash like
give me some feedback in the comments
and then of course on audio it always
means the world if you can rate and
review the podcast and no joke like if
you just take a second to leave a review
on Apple podcast um it really helps us
over there as well as this is an audio
and a video podcast but number four is
character number four is character this
one's interesting so character or
personal
makeup um character is the personal
details personal makeup of someone that
allows you to trust them now what Dr
Henry
cloud in the book trust breaks down here
is that there's two aspects to character
there's the permission to play
traits though but those are just the
basics and then there's the specific
traits needed for the area with which
you're going to trust somebody here's
the
difference if we limit character to
saying the person won't lie cheat or
steal that's not
enough that's foundational because that
should be permission to play like it it
would not it shouldn't be bragging if
you're like you know one of the coolest
things about our company is like we're
honest and it maybe in today's world
it's like whoa are you serious like the
last nine companies I were but like of
course like of course honesty and
integrity and like not lying or cheating
should be foundational but he brings up
something so powerful in the book by the
way uh we'll link this up in the show
notes as we do but this book is I really
think essential reading we're pulling
out just this very obscure vertical of
writing a YouTube script weaving this
into your business and your sales
messaging this will improve your
relationships improve you as a leader
help you better understand how to
rebuild trust there's obviously a lot of
stuff we can't cover have you ever
wondered
why you go you know I don't really trust
that person maybe you're talking and
it's in your workplace or maybe you work
with your spouse and you think about
somebody you're in a relationship with
and you're like I just don't I don't
really trust them and then you go
through a filter and you're like do I
think they would lie or steal money from
me and you're like no I don't think they
would ever lie I don't think they would
steal I think they're honest so then
it's like why would I why would I not
trust them and it's because the specific
traits for the area you need to trust
them are not there for example maybe
you're around somebody's easily angered
they they their their emotions get the
better of them that's not lying that's
not stealing but it shows that their
emotional stability is insufficient for
certain scenarios so you don't put them
in those scenarios if you need somebody
who's stoic and emotionally stable in
for the scenario that you need to trust
the person in then that's the wrong
person and it's not a bad thing but
you're like oh okay I get it now I get
why like I don't trust that person so
how could this apply to our videos well
as we are putting out all of our mess
messaging you're posting YouTube shorts
long form videos videos on social media
you are communicating your character in
as much as people can see that public
Persona that you're putting out there
and I hope they would see your honesty
and integrity your messaging should be
consistent across all touch points like
you know for us if if we we have um
different promotions that we do for some
of our programs and they have deadlines
and the pricing and the bonus
combination and the details of what's in
that offer does end um one of the thing
and one of the things that makes me
uncomfortable sometimes when people do
web classes they have like fake chat I
don't know if you've ever been on one of
these and they have like fake literally
like fake Bots and you're like this
isn't even a real conversation and they
they just do those are some honesty
Integrity things these little touch
points can erode your trust in that
person's
character but then as you work with or
watch a Creator more deeply you might
want to trust let's say them to be
stable how about being consistent like
being inconsistent on YouTube is not an
ethical problem like you're not like oh
wow he stopped posting he's evil you
know what I mean like she stopped
posting she's evil no she's probably
honest and full of integrity and full of
character but I can't trust them so are
you being consistent because you made a
promise with your content with your
Channel with your video podcast and you
show up and you deliver than video
podcast comes out Tuesday and Thursday
count on it like we're delivering if the
schedule CH changes please forgive us
but like ultimately then that builds
character builds trust the consistency
of this podcast builds Trust whether or
not you're like I don't think Shawn
would cheat lie or
steal but I need other character traits
like
consistency if you're going to trust if
I Pro promote certain values I I have
certain values where I actually I I
actually encourage our team our number
one core value at our business is the
Bible is our blueprint that there is a
higher authority than my opinion or
somebody else's opinion to how I conduct
myself so I don't want to
gossip or be divisive or disrespect
people's boundaries or go into anger or
create drama or just do different things
that would be outside of of the
character that I aspire to again not
necessarily right or wrong but think
about how you could include that in your
videos and the question for you is are
you getting the trust and the respect
that you want with your YouTube content
and if you take a hard look at your
consistency you know you might make a
statement like the number one YouTube
channel on the internet that solves this
problem the best content that solves
this problem subscribe because we are
committed those are good promises to
make but then the hard part is can you
back it up and are you slacking a little
bit are you putting out c-level content
when you know you could do B+ A+ level
content you used to research five and 10
hours in your videos now you you wing it
that again is maybe reasonable but I'm
not going to trust you and the trust of
the super fans and raving fans you want
to build could be
eroding and so that is character and
then number five track record track
record the track record is performing in
the way that you trust them to perform
over time if the track record is
broken it's hard to rebuild and Behavior
builds expectation so it delivers on a
promise you won't depend on someone
based on the last break of trust so this
again puts us this puts pressure on us
as content creators number one how can I
communicate my track record so if you
say I've been in business you know and
over the last 16 years on YouTube so
think about how that applies to you
that's what I say I mean at least it
shows a little bit of history and Legacy
on the platform I've been doing video
for 20 years YouTube for 16 it's gon to
be track record it might also apply to
ability now it also might not because
just because you've been doing something
for 16 years doesn't actually mean
you're good at it you know some people
were like I have 10 years of experience
and it's like no you don't you have one
year of experience repeated 10 times
like if you're not learning improving
and getting better then it doesn't
necessarily mean your track record can
deliver however your track record is how
you build a brand your track record is
how you build trust it's one thing to be
like okay he got lucky once it's one
thing to be like she had one good video
it's other thing to say like oh man
never misses man she consistently
delivers man they're they're good for it
by the way again one of the reasons we
encourage you to eventually package what
you know into a product for many in the
crater economy and especially in the
education vertical of content creation
which many of the thick media podcast
Community is in right we have
entertainers as well but a lot of us
right are doing that education side of
things so it's incredibly relevant that
she would someday make an online course
and join the e-learning industry
but here's the pressure is we would
never encourage you to just like put out
some mediocre product to just rush that
to just do it as a cash grab to not
deeply care about what you build and the
time you put in and making something
that's
great and by the way whether that's our
opinion or not the results will show
when the instant you finally offer
something to your audience and they join
it and they're like this isn't good then
why would they want to join other things
the reverse is true if whatever you put
out there when you package something
premium if they go holy goodness this
thing's amazing you actually have built
trust track record so if you offer
something else they might Pro they might
not need and probably don't need any
explanation why because of trust because
at that point they're like okay this
person clearly understood me their
motive is for me because they got me the
results they had the ability to do it
because I live the results I love the
product I love the experience I love the
video I love the program I love the
Discord group I love the paid Community
I love The Mastermind I love the event
their character in this vertical you
know like I I'm not hiring this person
for marriage counseling yes like they're
maybe aren't great at relationships and
they've been through a divorce and some
other things and I didn't hire them for
marriage advice I hired them for
business advice so it's like character
in a particular
vertical their their like like they have
proven to get results in this area
I didn't hire them to learn about
empathy and love because they don't have
that but I hired them because they're
really good at systems so character in
that vertical and then track record um
they have a history of doing it over
time and so
practically as we summarize if you're
writing out a YouTube script if you're
creating a sales message or a sales
video If even on YouTube you're thinking
about this video as a real estate agent
loan officer as somebody has an agency
or does freelance work and wants to be
hired can you see now how you actually
could being aware of these five elements
include these in your next video Hey
listen I get it I get what you're going
to I know that's frustrating and I've
been there and I can relate that's the
understanding you know our mission here
is to help 1 million purpose-driven
people create a full-time living doing
what they love while making a difference
with YouTube and we have different
products and programs in different ways
you can engage with us depending on your
budget but we're here to serve you we're
here to help youn that's the motive you
know and then you know uh over the past
16 years on YouTube I've built multiple
YouTube channels I've helped different
people and it's not just I that I've
done it because actually one of the
biggest things people doubt is not your
ability to do it they just found you on
the internet they discovered you can
pull it off they're helpful they're glad
you're sharing tips but the greater area
of self-doubt is in the individual not
that you there is skepticism perhaps of
your results so if you're backing up
your results with receipts and proof and
screenshots it's helpful but one of the
most powerful things you could do with
ability is demonstrate your ability if
you're an educator that you have gotten
results for other people that are just
like them and because then that's
actually what's
relatable and so can you weave in
demonstrating your your ability with
some case studies with some results with
some screenshots with some
data can you then also articulate or
express your character and also just
continue to demonstrate your character
with consistency and then similarly
similarly with track record can you
compound this one word of warning Dr
Henry Cloud mentions that track record
can be deceiving and he mentioned Bernie
made off and the Ponzi scheme I believe
it's a really good Netflix special I
didn't even know the Bernie made off uh
story really until I watched it on
Netflix because he was doing a Ponzi
scheme it would seem that he was
delivering the results he was getting
helping people cuz he was people were
getting paid out and so word of mouth
was
this is a good investment and on and on
and on and I want to say it lasted like
over 10 years so this should be
encouraging that we can still make
mistakes and sometimes when it seems
like all the all five things seem right
all things seem like they're going well
uh his encouragement in the book is that
while track record is a good indicator
you never know everything and you can't
always see behind the scenes and so
that's definitely something to be
consider when you're assessing Trust
with someone else but again for you
personally the better you can
communicate your history your
reputation um and then of course the
word of mouth of what's being said about
working with you watching you if people
are sharing if they've working with your
business referrals all of those things
can be super super helpful so how can I
weave these five elements into my videos
into my sales calls my sales Pages my
sales messages my emails um and why do
you trust some people and you don't
trust others this might illuminate some
of those things and perhaps you feel
inspired I actually bought the book and
the audio book so we'll link those up um
and uh I love this book so much been
talking about it it's been challenging
me and I've been thinking about it in my
relationship with my wife in our
business in friendships but also how can
I improve my next video now before we
land the plane I want to remind you that
right now we have a special sale going
on at V podcast.com once a year
especially during the holidays we do
some special promos and offers so you
can gear up and get ready to crush
YouTube in the next year and 2024 is
going to be big so I want to encourage
you check out the link in the show notes
or go to V podcast.com to see all of the
details this program has transformed
countless people's lives over 10,000
students we have lots of case studies
and stories about the impact and this is
really the seven step system that I
created that will help you create videos
that get views and monetize those videos
in multiple different ways so if you're
ready to stop dabbling and to start
dominating on YouTube to take your
YouTube growth super serious to invest
to step up your gr game and to go all in
especially with the new year coming then
check out V podcast.com and I want to
thank you for being a part of this
community uh subscribe of course if
you're not subscribed and maybe consider
who could you share the think media
podcast with perhaps this episode was
Illuminating if you do watch the video
version I would love to hear your
biggest takeaway and insight in the
comments section and of course on audio
there's no way to comment but if you
rate and review the podcast that is one
way to send your love and appreciation
back my way if and only if you find the
think media podcast valuable I
appreciate you so much and I can't wait
to see you in the next episode until
then Sean canell rhymes with YouTube
channel and we will talk soon